kabir kareem often returns to this
street in west london
his 20-year-old brother alex was shot
dead here in june
police believe alex was killed in a case
of mistaken identity
a 16 year old boy was one of nine people
arrested over his death
and eight months after alex's funeral no
one has been charged
i'm able to come here sometimes i have
to come here just to reflect
i feel almost coming here just you know
i think coming is
it's the closest i've i'll i'll get to
uh almost
reliving him him and why because this
was his last steps this was his last
breath
you know about like my mom's she can't
handle it honestly the last time she
came here she was she was hysterical
she was in tears she was screaming she
was wailing on the street
the police in parts of the country are
worried about gun crime and children are
getting involved
sky news can reveal more than 600
children were arrested for suspected
firearm offences in the uk last year
the youngest was 12. police figures
obtained by sky news show that 171 ewes
were detained by the metropolitan police
for alleged firearm crimes in 2020
that was up from 165 the previous year
in the west midlands 86 children were
arrested over firearms
among them two twelve-year-old boys and
on merseyside a fourteen-year-old girl
was arrested for a suspected firearm
offence
two years earlier an 11 year old was
arrested there for a firearm crime
the west midlands had some of the most
alarming figures
and one former gang member who carried a
gun when he was 15
has seen it coming the real issue is it
all really boils down
to a way of thinking a mindset and
and a culture a culture that's being
pushed and is thriving
throughout um the whole country it
started off
in little communities like mine but this
mentality this way of thinking is like a
virus it spreads
it started spreading throughout the
school systems i remember seeing it
when i had just left school started
getting into
um gang violence and crime
and the the way of thinking started to
spread it was just my community at first
now it's asian it's the asian community
it's the white community
it's everyone the national police
chief's council said overall gun crime
in the uk
remains low it said it's working to
break the cycle of young people becoming
involved in gangs
alex kareem would have turned 21 this
month
he'd planned to go to university to
study computer science
his family believes someone out there
knows who killed him
david mercer sky news